Mike and Dave need wedding dates stars
Zac Efron and Adam Devine as the two
brothers that you really don't want to
invite to anything important because
they'll probably ruin it they have a
long history of disasters at family
events and so their parents asked them
to bring some respectable wedding dates
to their little sister's wedding and
they find Aubrey Plaza and Anna Kendrick
who are actually just pretending to be
respectable these two girls just want to
go on a trip to Hawaii
but they actually are even worse in some
ways than Mike and Dave are yeah they
love their ecstasy they really do so
naturally things don't go as planned and
we now have a big screwball comedy and
that's really what Mike and Dave need
wedding dates is it's a screwball comedy
and if you're going to this movie
knowing that and you're fans of these
actors then you'll probably have a good
time if you went to this movie just
wanting to see a comedy and that's all
you want
you'll probably really enjoy yourself
and there were moments when I laughed
there were some jokes that really worked
some stuff that really worked for me and
the characters themselves these two
brothers these two guys they work really
well together and the editing is so fast
and fierce the comedy comes along pretty
fast sometimes it doesn't work though
and a lot of that is due to the fact
that this movie is kind of a cartoon
there are times where it almost feels
like a fantasy because people are
getting away with things and saying
things and going on and on and taking
the joke just one step too far where
you're like I'm in a movie and I'm
trying to get a laugh this isn't real
I'm in a movie I'm an actor and this is
the part where I get laughs and there
are a lot of parts like that where it
goes from being a believable event to
one step too far and it becomes a
cartoon also there is something with the
four principal characters in this movie
Efron Devine Plaza and Kendrick they
don't really feel like people and to
best describe what I mean I'll talk
about somebody I met one time and never
hung out with again for a very specific
reason he was a friend of a friend and I
met him and he was a nice guy and
everything but there was something he
kept doing
he kept audibly saying internet phrases
he would laugh and go haha lol or he
would say things like dat ass doe
hashtag damn legs right and after a few
hours like that I was just making mental
notes like remember too
yeah with my friend when this person is
not present the four main characters in
this movie are very much like that
they're like Internet people that's just
what it kind of seems like they don't
really feel like real people they just
feel like fake movie people and
sometimes this movie is really funny and
I think most people who go to this movie
just wanting to laugh are going to laugh
because you know what I did laugh i
overall had a good time with this movie
that's because in the end the characters
do become a lot more endearing they do
show themselves as human beings and
that's where the movie won me over in
the end when these characters stop being
joke meme people and became actual
characters in a movie and you saw that
there was some depth going on or at
least an attempt to and that added with
some really good comedy and some good
chemistry between most of these actors I
had a good time overall with this movie
and I'm gonna give it a b-minus it does
kind of become a cartoon in parts where
they take the joke just that one extra
step further and you're like that's okay
you're in a movie now I get it you're an
actor good job but overall I think the
most people who go to this movie who
just want to laugh we'll guys thank you
so much
as always for watching I had a review
coming very soon for Lego Star Wars The
Force awakens a video game that I did
not plan on reviewing until I played it
and a review for the hunt for the will
Derby
thank you so much guys for watching and
if you liked this you can click right
here and get stubborn eyes